[Music]
he's done it again
my friend stephen crowder oh he's been a
very naughty boy he's in trouble now and
uh not just a little trouble not just
like youtube gonna censor a couple
things he says he's in like permanently
get banned from youtube and lose his
entire career and platform and voice
kind of potential trouble and
i hate to say it
it's actually sort of our fault here at
the daily wire stephen
thank you for coming on
uh thank you for putting me in a fight
for my life i appreciate it so this just
to give a little context here the daily
wire
we have prided ourselves on making a
business mostly out of uh silly click
bait headlines and you know just like uh
10 ways that we destroy the libs and
stuff like that but recently
we have because the the site has been
very successful and we're very grateful
to all of the members we have invested
in actual investigative journalism which
the right rarely does we usually use the
investigative journalism from the new
york times or the washington post and
then we try to take out all the bias and
take out all the craziness but we
actually broke a story ourselves which
is that in loudoun county a girl was
raped allegedly in a bathroom by a
guy
who sometimes wears a skirt and the
story here is obviously
that these transgender bathroom policies
are probably not the best idea and
further the story is that the the school
covered it up and they denied it but now
even the washington post has to
acknowledge it you
talked about this news story that
actually happened in reality
yeah and now you don't get to be on
youtube because
uh pretty much yeah and by the way that
i really do appreciate the work that you
guys did i did reach out to your senior
uh i guess editors there and i said look
i need to have some kind of confirmation
i know you you can't reveal all this all
of us publicly because they are minors
but that the rape kit was conducted and
that the police confirmed it and so what
i saw certainly seemed as though you
guys had done your due diligence so i
don't know when you say allegedly when
there's a rape kit uh we did a full hour
just to be clear for people who are
wondering we have a heart strike on the
channel right now so we cannot stream to
youtube for people who are wondering
where we are of course mug club you know
we have merch at fight like hell uh
crowdershop.com we're at rumble apple
spotify we'll be back in a week but what
happened is we did an hour show on the
loudoun county story because it does get
a little complicated when you understand
the timeline and you're going wait a
second there were there were two rapes
yes there were wait a second the father
was in trouble for complaining about the
rape
yes he was so we thought this was really
a pivotal story and sometimes people say
hey you don't get bothered with the
culture wars this is actually the most
important subject of our time and and
this kind of encapsulates it and i'll
explain why we did that for uh about the
hour show most of it was devoted to
loudoun county that was on uh what when
was that was that uh thursday was that
tuesday wednesday
yeah it was just just a couple of days
ago it was yeah this was tuesday sorry
yes okay so the strike came from i
believe a show last thursday but it came
immediately after the loudoun county
show which was poised to hit you know a
million viewers within the day uh for
the whole show and what they struck us
for was a story we covered
last week
where there were
transgender uh transgender individuals
have been declaring in record numbers
that they are females going into female
prisons and now in california they have
pregnancy protocols and a woman got
impregnated in a california prison and
so the joke was on youtube where we said
so on transgender inmates uh
female brave and beautiful inmates a
woman got pregnant
immaculate conception and we did a
sketch where the angel came to mary and
said a sign
be not afraid for she'll be assigned on
to you she said a virgin birth and he
said uh it was actually alex jones who
was the angel he said uh no you'll be
sexually assaulted by your transgender
cellmate repeatedly that was the joke
now there's a carve out on youtube for
comedy to be clear people need to
understand this the joke was we never
insinuated that they were anything other
than a beautiful and brave female which
is of course absurd right um
the language that came from the lawyer
though it was immediately after the
loudon story
but they said we're going to hit you
retroactively for this the language said
you are not allowed to express you know
violence against individuals or indicate
or indicate that transgender individuals
may pose a rape threat to women
that's game systems they're not they're
not capable of doing it it's they're
physically incapable of ever po when
when husky hank walks into the women's
bathroom he is not physically capable of
harming a woman according to youtube
he's not you can't talk about specific
instances and some people are saying
well you should be able to speak about
specific instances but you shouldn't be
able to voice the broad concern i
disagree let me explain to you why there
were over a hundred parents as you guys
reported in loudoun county right who
said oh a rape oh a second rape were
concerned antennae up and they wanted to
protest this policy saying we believe
that this pose is
a sexual assault threat to our young
daughters right that's why the parents
lined up you can say that in the town
square you can say that in a municipal
meeting you say that on youtube if you
say that on facebook you're banned
you're gone and here's the issue
speaking with ben shapiro about this you
could say
male of course males pose a threat to uh
to to female uh inmates or classmates
insert whatever here the problem is the
language game where now it's you can't
even say biological male is hate speech
all right i'll use your term transgender
you can't say that they could pose a
threat to women because they're women
well what do you do this literally makes
it so nobody can oppose any policies and
here's the thing we're doing some
research now it is terrifying the amount
of small channels
that have covered your story or that
have covered similar stories who are
gone i'm fortunate i'm blessed people
have supported us with mug club you have
daily wire
but what about the people who never get
a chance to grow that's the issue and
this is their new policy from by the way
the one solace i find is very very
expensive legal council who had to watch
that entire episode and watch the sketch
and do a write-up so at least at least i
have that that is a silver lining in a
storm cloud this to me seems like an
acceleration of something that happened
to me it was either a week or two ago
i played a clip from the cdc director
rochelle wolenski and the cdc director
in this clip says that the coronavirus
can be spread
by people who have the vaccine right
which is something that we all know
that's obviously true that's the
argument for why the vaccinated people
should wear the masks is that they can
still transmit the virus i i just quoted
her i just i i had the
these scientific authority one of the
top three in in the world according to
the liberal establishment i just use her
words i was told that this was
a violation of the youtube policy
because youtube says you are not allowed
to say that the vaccine does not prevent
transmission of the virus even if you're
the director of the cdc so that
obviously outrageous this
an even greater acceleration of that you
are reporting on a very important news
story that the left was suppressing that
the school was suppressing that that
threatens young women and girls and
because of that you could yes hopefully
you'll be back next week but you could
permanently lose your channel
we we absolutely could and here's the
thing i want to be clear they didn't say
it's the loudoun county story they
picked something that was a comedy
sketch that was milder from the previous
week it happened immediately after the
show i mean youtube has been gunning for
us for for years because you know okay
we are the most watched conservative
show on youtube we're the most
look
we're the most watched conservative show
in the demo of all time it's not even
close the next closest second is tucker
carlson we do three times as much i
don't talk about these the reason i talk
about this right now is because this is
an attack on people who watch the show
this is an attack from youtube saying no
no no we're gonna auto play seth meyers
no no no this guy can't be colbert no no
no this is hate speech they really don't
want what we do to get out there and the
issue here is they have framed in
language so much that it doesn't allow
one side to speak a genuine thought
exercise for people out there let's say
you're a parent okay you are a parent
and you want to express concern over a
new transgender bathroom policy because
two people were raped in loudoun county
how do you express your concern over
that policy
online with the rules they just set out
you cannot imply there's a rape threat
you can't do it and so when people say
oh is this a culture worse thing way
more important than taxes yes
obviously this is the fight i mean if
you're not going to fight this fight
then who cares who cares if you're going
to like slightly reform the
administrative state but it's not going
to do anything but but it's it's not
even as though we're just talking about
online you know well
look you can't voice your opinion on
this public matter online uh but you can
do it offline so what i'm going to go
get a bell and start swinging it in the
village square no the the public square
in our society today is online and
specifically it's on google and youtube
which is owned by google and it's on
facebook and to a lesser degree it's on
twitter and that's it and these
oligarchs control i love that slide to
twitter it's true
i love that slide to twitter dorsey is
always he's always like hey guys what
are you doing do you want to go get some
uh some uh shrimp fajitas and they're
like ghetto jack come on go go back to
go back to castaway
it's not even close if people look at
the stock it's not even close it's not
it's not and so if you if you control
speech in self-government in a republic
you control the whole thing so right now
what are we supposed to do i mean i i
i'm furious i can i can yell about this
until i am blue in the face but we we
need to make these content decisions and
we have a little more breadth here
because our platforms are bigger as you
say the smaller channels that are
they're just being snuffed out in the
crib so what are we supposed to do if if
youtube comes out and says you're not
allowed to say x y and z do you
do you try to twist your language do you
go along do you take a brave courageous
stand and then get your channel shut
down what are we supposed to do
i won't do it and i'll tell you why i
won't do it i've never implied that all
transgenders are rapists i've never
implied that all transgenders are a rape
threat because i don't believe it i've
never implied it i wouldn't say it i've
had transgender individuals on my show a
lot of times people are confused by how
loving and kind i am to them and
gracious as a host and they go oh so you
must not believe what you talk about
with transgenders no i absolutely do i
also love you as a person as we're
supposed to show love through christ
that's what we're supposed to reflect
but absolutely uh biology is a real
thing and i won't go along with this
language we will fight it legally we are
continuing to stream uh on on um i was
about to say youtube on rumble and on
mug club where we have people who
support us you know a lot of the times
people say go and create your own
platform well it's not possible when
they lock you out here's an exp here's
an experiment i want everyone to do okay
search for anything specific right now
on youtube it used to be the reason for
the protection let's say for youtube it
was a search engine right you search for
something you found it this is true this
is a true story i i have this like town
home that we're using for employees who
come in and airbnb and uh i'm a coffee
snub so i was like wait the person can't
use this whole pour over well i'm not
gonna get a keurig because i don't want
to be one of those guys my mom gave me a
nespresso machine you're italian you
know so she gave me an espresso i love
nespresso
okay well i hate it but you're so you're
olive garden italian i guess you should
have a machine with dials and copper
like willy wonka but if you're doing
nespresso all right
i won't
that was jesus's last miracle at the
last supper was the never-ending salad
bowl so um this just never ends he's
like i'm jesus what do you think so
anyway she gives me this nespresso
machine i'm like okay how do i use this
i go and search on youtube nespresso
pixie machine and i knew there was a
danger because i was putting pixie in
the name right but i searched an
espresso pixie machine
and two results come up and then a bunch
of results of late night comedy
political stuff other coffee but nothing
to do with nespresso today on youtube it
cannot be used as a search engine it's
not possible it is entirely now a
curation and they will hide behind the
algorithms but their algorithms are
determined by policies that say
you can never even indicate that
transgenders may pose a rape threat to
women so i'm talking about coffee it
doesn't matter but what if someone types
in
loudoun county rape they might get two
results of the truth so when people say
go and build your own youtube go and
build your own twitter or facebook it's
not possible because these entities are
one and the same with government right
now they're more powerful than the roman
empire and so we have to do what you do
when we do you have daily wire and
you're also on youtube because you want
to reach people and we have mug club and
listen we will fight like hell on this
we always will we'll fight it legally we
will fight it in the public square and
people who think that they aren't coming
for you look this is
you
anyone who is watching right now if you
think that you have the right to say
i'm concerned for my daughter going into
a changing room with a biological male
which by the way you're also not allowed
to say now they're considering that hate
speech they want a new term instead of
biological male if you are at home and
you're saying i want to voice my concern
youtube facebook twitter is saying you
won't be able to period
that's terrifying what i don't
understand here is how they can say with
a straight face that transgender
individuals or
biological men as opposed to what
psychological men or spiritual matter i
don't know whatever jargon they want to
use how they can say that they don't
pose
any threat to women when they're in
places where women are changing or you
know otherwise sort of vulnerable they
don't pose any threat zero you're
telling me you're telling me google that
whether it's a man or you want to call
him not a man or you want to call him
whatever jargon you have
he it's impossible for him to pose any
kind of what are you taught i mean
that's just so indefensible so how do
they how do they get away with it
well your first mistake your your
premise is flawed you said how do they
say with a straight face they say it
with an angry lesbian face let's be
honest those are the people who are
saying this in silicon valley and angry
faces um vastly overrepresented here
where look they're gonna have a
transgender walkout at netflix on
october 20th
if if we're talking about the
demographics
of the population right because now they
want democrat if black people make up 12
percent of the american population they
should make up at least 12 percent of
the oscars they make up exponentially
more
compared to the population in silicon
valley they're going to walk out on
netflix first off
eddie murphy's going to be circling that
walk out in a limo i mean that is just
absolutely a perfect scenario for him
probably hugh grant
a little bit going back to the 90s here
but yeah i don't they don't say it with
the straight face they're not trying to
actually avoid people's feelings being
hurt there is absolutely
an uh a deliberate attempt to control
language and too many conservatives have
conceded ground and say oh it's about
the deficit listen all of those things
matter but if the idea of man and woman
i believe it says i believe that's
described in the bible somewhere near
the back man and woman if that ceases to
be
i am not an alarmist people know i've
always been sort of what they say happy
warrior silver lining
if we cease to have man and woman there
will be no country left there is no more
western civilization and look right
absolutely there should be no hate
speech
and i don't want to use the term hate
speech absolutely you shouldn't walk up
to a transgender individual and chastise
them or treat them
any more poorly than you would anybody
else you should love them you should
treat them with respect i believe that a
lot of these people especially when you
look at a 42 attempted suicide rate and
the post-operative status is not any
better we just talked about uh
the ministry of justice in the uk 59
of male to female transgender inmates uh
have committed sexual assault 59
only males there it's 16
biological females it's 3 so the numbers
are off the charts if you look at this i
i do think that there's a group of
people in need of love and help but how
do you love and help someone if there's
a 60 sexual assault right ministry of
justice uk we have a reference available
on the website um in prison how do you
help them if you don't say look look
there's something here that maybe isn't
working we need we need to correct
you can't do it well just you know we
talk about these sort of statistics and
these a lot of these i actually hadn't
heard before so it's you know this is of
justice in the uk
it's a specific prison study and it
shocked me yes no and so that's all very
important
there's also this ontological issue
which is
men are not women men who think that
their women are delusional and they
should be corrected and they should it's
not compassionate to allow them to live
in lies and it's not uh compassionate to
force society to indulge those kinds of
delusions and this is common sense and
everyone agreed with it until about five
minutes ago and you're not allowed to
say that anymore and and youtube is
enforcing it to varying degrees on
different people and right now you're in
the hot seat so then the question to me
is let's say that they just they've just
finally had enough of you mr crowder and
you've
pissed them off one too many times what
what happens is is that the end of
louder with crowd or is i mean is there
does it mean you're not gonna have a
show anymore does it mean you're not
what is it what does it look like if
they actually work we're still
no we're still streaming to give you an
idea we were streaming and of course
there are larger numbers on youtube
where there used to be way larger
numbers because people would find us
through the algorithms that's not
possible but uh yesterday we were
streaming the show off of youtube and we
still had over 60 64 000 live viewers at
any given second which you know turns to
a rolling average which will which will
be in the high six figures or in the
million range without youtube so no uh
although it's really important to me to
reach the unreached you know our average
viewer is a 28 year old male or woman
and that doesn't happen youtube right
now is saying over a million over a
million 20 something year olds are
tuning in every show for over 40 minutes
whoa we've never had that it's okay when
they're off on fox news and they're
selling uh gold and and tom selleck's
telling you this isn't my first rodeo to
try and steal your home right they're
okay with that they're not okay with
these messages getting out right now
people like you people like ben people
like myself reaching a new audience and
by the way doing it in a way that is not
only accurate but fun look this is a
comedy show i'm a comedian i'm probably
going to start touring again with dave
landau once i'm no longer exhausted with
lawsuits but um
we are so meticulous because we know
we're in the hot seat with references
and sourcing i don't know that there's
any other program out there who provides
every single reference from on air in a
in a very uh a formatted way on a
website so that everyone can peruse them
and 90 of them are completely neutral
sources like pubmed or they're coming
from polls like zogby and if we use a
bias source we use a liberal source we
make it all publicly available as a
matter of fact we've seen a huge website
increase just from people going and
clicking through the references which is
what i want them to do i want people to
read more i want our show to be an hour
and i want them to spend two three four
hours researching for themselves
meanwhile shows that lie
jimmy kimmel did you see that jimmy
kimmel unironically used media matters
and slate as a source
and there's no problem with it and he
wasn't making a joke i mean i you know
come on that's that do i i don't need to
specify it's been a long time
yes redundant not make jimmy kimmel not
making a joke redundant it's like a
jumbo shrimp but he didn't make a joke
he was making a point from media matters
look people up there this is a if you
watch michael knowles you watch ben
shapiro you they are coming for you
even if your children are being raped
and i don't mean me too someone or even
chris cuomo grabbing someone's ass in
front of her husband which by the way i
don't know why that husband didn't beat
the tar out of chris cuomo i am talking
about forcible rape verified by a kit
and then done again and if you are a
parent
you are the one who will be vilified for
expressing concern look behind you
people that's the orwellian line and and
i mean it it's like that that meme from
the trump 2020 campus the best meme of
the whole campaign where it's this that
picture of trump and he says they're not
coming for me they're coming for you and
i just happen to be in the way and
that's what's happening and it's not
just for the smaller creators on youtube
it's for any parent who wants to speak
out against these preposterous policies
it's for any ordinary american who
doesn't like the way the ruling class is
governing and it's to this point you
made stephen it's about the discovery i
i agree if if youtube brings the hammer
down you'll be fine and you'll you're
going to keep your 100 of your audience
and you might even grow the audience a
little bit because it would be a news
story but you are not going to have
access to the growth of the audience
that everyone else is going to have
access to with new people discovering
this stuff it will be siloed it will be
ghettoized it will be it will be
ostracized from society which is i think
the long game here for the left which is
why i'm glad that you're uh making
making a little bit of one more thing
it's mental warfare michael it's mental
warfare you know it's the nazis saying
and i'm not saying that you two are
nazis but the nazis would say all is
lost if you have taken your bases right
they would go out and pump it through
all these small channels out there all
these smaller creators who who are
influenced look there's a term in comedy
like oh that guy's a dave a tell baby
that guy's a mitch hedberg baby meaning
a comedian who came up in that
generation was influenced there's a ben
shapiro baby there's a michael knowles
baby there's certainly a crowder baby
because i've been here since 2009 when
there were no conservatives they're
coming up and if the leaders get taken
if the leaders get picked off or just
influences i don't consider myself a
leader that demoralizes them what chance
does the kid with 10 000 subscribers
have that is what they are doing right
now they're trying to pick off the
generals and they're coming not just for
content creators they're coming for
parents they're coming for daughters
listen if you are a woman in 2021
you're gonna have to shut up and take it
on the chin that's what they're saying
right right it's blunt and it's
offensive and it's outrageous and it's
obviously true stephen we gotta leave it
there uh keep me posted we're going to
stop doing journalism now at the daily
wire so we don't keep getting you in
trouble we're going to stop reporting on
any actual facts and
relevant news stories uh at least for
what we have to at least stop it for a
week so they don't you completely uh but
everyone if you have not done it already
this should be the wake up call go do it
head on over to mug club go head on over
to any channel any alternative channel
that is going to allow you to continue
to see mr crowder's content because
uh we we can't rely on the on the big
entities here they are turning their
attention on the voices that they think
are the most dangerous to the liberal
narrative and at the moment that happens
to be mr stephen crowder thank you sir
see you next time
thank you so much my eye shadow
[Music]